I've been doing guys all right who here
saw Shazam this year who here loves
Shazam this year all right we've got a
very important piece of that majestic
Shazam puzzle we've got Billy Batson
himself as your angel give it up for
Asher
[Music]
wait there it is there's the matter of
Las Vegas how we feeling
now asher plays billy batson and you
guys are comic fans but billy batson
before last year was not a name that
like dramas and ida who knew but now
billy Batson's billy batson
what's it been like going from I'm
playing this character from the Silver
Age - holy crap Shazam's out things have
changed
no it's been insane we shot the movie in
Toronto for four months it was an
incredible experience kind of cold so it
was definitely hard but um it's it's
been crazy I mean we knew the movie was
something special from the beginning and
as soon as it came out and you guys
seeing you guys as reactions and you
guys loving it's been it's been great so
happy to be here yes I am and oh people
dressed as Shazam in that guy in the bag
it's just amazing - that's fantastic
like the costumes and everything ladies
laying in the world is so crazy what was
one of the craziest moments on the press
tour that was extensive so I mean we
went we went so many places first press
tour amazing kind of tiring but super
cool
probably our late night we had a lot of
late-night karaoke with Zach as you guys
know he loves to sing sings his little
heart out entangled he's great a little
time yeah like the week actually the
first one-on-one panel we did here last
year in Vegas so it's now been a year
anniversary of that and it crazy like
magic now that was white where are white
I was like was there another one
did I miss a thing in states so we did
the Hawaii and that was before the movie
came out so this is a different world
now what's the biggest experience you
had while working on like the movie
itself that changed how you saw comic
books this is a comic book art it's like
how did you see the comic book world
differently it's my dad over there happy
Father's Day for all the dads out here
first of all
I wasn't a huge comic book fan going
into it
I didn't know much about it but as soon
as I got the role I rushed to the comic
book store and got the new 52 and just
did as much research as possible and now
I'm the biggest comic book nerd ever and
I think it's I think it's really cool
that this converted them yeah that's yes
thank you guys
yes maybe yeah cuz I I saw you in Hawaii
picking up like old Silver Age books it
was so cool to see someone that was like
not in a comic book headspace until
getting the property picking up the
authentic the old-school the sixties
like you should see my room now one of
us so when you went from like the world
of TV into the world of movies I know
the budget obviously a big change and
all of those things doing stunts on that
scale and those different things but
then actually seeing it on the big
screen I was at the premiere and the
premiere you guys they shut down
Hollywood Boulevard and put up a ferris
wheel that's that's not a thing you do
it's crazy the moment you realized the
scope of the movie what was that like to
know like we filmed it I'm done it's
over but then to see the promotion the
posters the world and then the premiere
what was that first moment sure it was
it was amazing it's a surreal I I mean I
knew it was a DC movie and I knew that
it was going to be big but then watching
it all happen was just the craziest part
you know and just the press tour and all
the promotional stuff that we did was
just insane and then but the premiere
was when it really happened it was like
wow they have a ferris wheel in the
middle of Hollywood Boulevard with a
bunch of like other rides and is there's
that's all I can say like it's it's been
a dream now you guys have all seen the
movie right tell me I'm gonna go
spoilers okay the first time you saw
this Shazam alley which was what I call
them and I refused not to this is Amelie
on screen and knowing what an integral
part of that you were how crazy was it
to see a family of yours on screen all
with superpowers for the first time it
was beautiful you know it was beautiful
like it
in it was in the original script then
they took it out I was sad the whole
cast was sad then they put it back in
and then we everyone freaked out and
just seeing it happen was just
incredible and actually seeing it for
the first time on the big screen made it
even better and we made a movie it's
amazing
not a lot of people get to play a
character where someone else plays them
usually it's like a biopic or like that
you get to play a character that someone
else also plays you how weird was it
watching Zack train as you Oh weird
no it's so it's so weird because Zack
and I I was never there for for Zack
scenes so I had no idea how he was you
know portraying Billy I mean so he was
it was scary yeah it was scary
because I'm but we had similar facial
expressions and like little like I guess
similar mannerisms as well so it just it
all worked the first time I I saw any of
his scenes it was the first time I saw
the movie yeah it's married before that
which is kind of crazy so there's a
little nerve-racking watching the movie
for the first time and it's like oh my
god holy crab this is crazy it works so
Billy Batson discovered those Shazam
seems the way way we did which is crazy
like we all just experienced that
explosion of magic now that I've also
seen the movie the scene with you and
Iman Honsou is great it feels like a
comic book it is so much fun and I love
that there's that moment of like really
and that's the word you want to say that
at you
what was your experience working with
diem on dealing with magic in a set that
captivating like walking into a Cave of
Wonders well it felt like I was actually
there in the first place
it was huge they literally built that
inside of the stages and it's kind of
nervous to work with Jamin because it's
huge fan of diamond there's like oh my
gosh
so he's amazing I remember I got to work
with him for like three days best
probably one of my probably the best
three days of filming
because everything was so amazing but
best three days of filming was probably
with chimein doing those scenes because
those are like the iconic scenes and we
wanted to make sure that we were doing
them right
and it turned out great and he's a great
guy and hopefully he was gonna capture
Marvel as well which is funny I think
cats are Marvel and he was in Shazam and
I think they came out around the same
time which was pretty cool he shows up
and like he's in Constantine like he's
like the most comic actor he's a
Guardians he's everywhere he's amazing
you also had an amazing emotional arc
and I really like actor question you go
from this fun high school nodded like
the way the school is represented is
authentically a kid like it you feel
that like it felt like when you're in
school like the good and the bad but
then the stuff with your mom man is is
genuinely heartbreaking what was the
tone of set like on the high Jinxy days
versus the brutal scene where you
encounter the the arc of your character
and you becoming the adult you have to
be I mean we shot this we shot that
scene right out of the gate I I got in
and like a day day later I did that
scene so I literally had to prepare for
that pretty fast which um it was kind of
nice though because I actually got to
work with my mom before that which was
really helpful so my audition scenes
were that so I was kind of already
prepared for that I think that was the
scene that got me the job which is
pretty amazing but I was I was prepared
going into it I think I wasn't really
nervous about it
I mean usually every day we go to set
Zach brings this big speaker and he's
playing all this weird music I don't
know I need to fix his playlist it's
interesting so that training montage was
just the filming b-roll and I cut it
together just let him go
you're speaker now speaking of playlist
speaking of music that's a love that you
have like profoundly your music is a
giant part of your life and it's it's
blowing up man it's crazy thank you it's
so cool to see like acting and music and
art and creation like exist in this way
what what brought you into music like
how'd that start I mean I started off
doing musical theater so that's kind of
where I found my love for all of it and
came out to LA to try and pursue a
career in acting and I kept doing voice
lessons as well and just kept going with
everything and
that's starting to take off as well I
just signed with Ellie reads record
label 45 days ago and I just released a
song with Wiz Khalifa that went number
one trending worldwide on YouTube which
is pretty cool so I'm the only 16 and
just I can't believe I get to do this
and at such a young age and I'm just
very thankful and blessed yeah it's
amazing
do you have a different creative process
for acting versus music you get like you
know like more coffee less coffee
different hat like is there a wish I I
wish I'd like to coffee that's the thing
I don't like coffee and everyone and all
of my friends I don't like coffee it's
fine I like hot chocolate is that bad if
I drink huh see is it bad if I drink hot
chocolate when I'm like you know older
is that bad thank you dude trade secret
it's gonna stunt my growth right if I
drink it now traits Duncan chinos is
pretty much just a hot chocolate and you
just pretend it's a coffee it's like the
adult equivalent and pretending you're
drinking coffee but like when you're
when you're working on music is it does
it feel different or does it is it just
like creation
it's just creation no yeah I mean for
music when I'm writing songs I usually
grab my guitar and like I kind of I mean
most of the songs I write I kind of just
put in things that have happened in my
life like incorporate those kind of
things and just the way I'm feeling you
know it's kind of like writing how I'm
feeling on paper which helps and then
you turn it into a song it's kind of my
process it's been the same process since
I started so it's kind of the process
how it works so music movies a lot of
movement that videos awesome man thank
you and Wiz Khalifa yeah what was it
like working with Wiz freakin Khalifa uh
another dream of mine yeah yes I'm a
huge whisk fan I've wanted to work with
him for a long time and as soon as I got
this song I was like oh my gosh guys I
know this is a long shot
but let's get Wiz khlifa on the song and
of course everyone looked at me like I
was crazy cuz I was crazy I was crazy
yeah it's Wiz Khalifa and actually one
of the producers knew him
it's his name's hitmaker he's produced
so many songs that are number one on the
charts right now and he walks out of the
studio he's got whiz on the phone and
I'm like trying not to hyperventilate in
the corner over there and
and you like the song he loved it two
days later he recorded it a week later I
got it back released the week later and
then we just shot the music video now
that's out so what happens really fast
it's it's crazy guys thank you guys
thanks for coming out
I love you guys now we've got another
Shazam surprise for you guys
because I think the Shazam Lee is such a
unique and beautiful thing in comic book
films I'd like to welcome to the stage
Jaffa yo man what's up man now we were
talking before about that moment at the
end of the movie I want to start there
when when there's a transformation as as
a Shazam fan like that's such a huge
part of comic lore what was it like
working on a part that you knew someone
else was gonna play you later
I don't know what's from him but it was
kind of waiting for me I was like wait
wait how somebody gonna play me that's a
little interesting a role um but it was
definitely really cool to see who was
playing my counterpart DJ cotrona yeah
yeah give it up for DJ oh he's a good
looking man so that's a good counterpart
you know ripped I'm good it's good to
see that they think highly of me they
think I'll have a beard just amazing so
you know it's definitely really cool and
we didn't really get to work with them
because they are our counterparts yeah
so I think on our rap days when we
finally got to be on the same set for
the first time and it was our last day
it was it was really beautiful it was
awesome
I think everyone cried this guy cried
crocodile hey cried yeah look you see
themselves in the future it's a
beautiful moment yeah usually takes an
existential crisis to find yourself
you guys got to find them on set exactly
now what was the set like did you guys
Lee get to like hang out there's a lot
of great family scenes I really love how
they treat the foster family because any
families of family and I think that's a
really great message of this movie that
blood isn't family families family and
you guys choose your family what was the
set life life at those like tables and
on those days well I think um I mean for
all of us it was it was just like it was
on
you know it was not blood that bonded us
together but just you know a bond and
then we really got together together off
set and hung out and that I feel with
some of the more fun moments because we
really we really went crazy we went to a
maple farm
I threw a tomahawk I got the bull's eye
he did it competitive at all yeah the
aquarium we did we went to the aquarium
yeah what else we went to the Toronto
Blue Jays game that's pretty sick yeah
we had a box yeah ever been in a box you
probably have you uh uh no it was so
cool it was awesome that's crazy
did they win I don't remember I don't
think I was so excited just to be in the
box and I was taking videos and selfies
inside the box up ahead and watch the
game we were there with the Titans cast
that was pretty cool yeah yeah set up -
have you gotten to the world of comics
like Asher has now that you're in that
world yeah well I was already a big fan
of Shazam ahead of time and the flash
and Superman that that was my childhood
my mom used to have to take my Superman
onesie off while I was asleep to wash it
cuz I would not take it off and then I
had the little Superman curl coming down
so yeah it was DC was definitely always
a part of my childhood and just to be a
part of the DCU now it's just such an
honor and it feels amazing especially
because I did get to read some of the
comic books in the new 52 I know me and
Asher we got some boxes of the new one
so we got to catch up but definitely
excited to be a part of the DCU now
we're living in I mean we can't really
argue this is the Golden Age of comic
books like there's never been anything
like this before and it's only getting
cooler like things are just getting
better movies are getting more awesome
is there anything you guys want to see
like a hypothetical that we haven't
gotten yet your universe or not like
Lincoln comic looks like a movie like I
get like in the world of comic films is
there a because we were talking that
Kevin Eastman right before and I want to
say Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and
Deadpool now
I had a good one but I guess I found a
comic I have to think of another one who
would you want to see Sam with and this
is their family Carrie crossover movie
superhero team-up Bowman or a team-up
yeah I think flashes Shazam would be
really good together he did that because
he knows he's my fav yeah it's his
favorite obviously flash would be a good
one if not flash Superman come on be
pretty good also who do you think would
win a man team that race they're both
Lightning base exactly which is very
specific who do you guys think in an
array sweet Shazam and flash we got
flash and remember you're at the Shazam
panel
that's why she's Sam comes second or
Shazam it's okay to be biased that's the
right answer that's correct Sam wins
this race whoa now we're going through
this this movie time we're spring movies
are like summer movies like you guys
movie came out and it was insane it was
huge and it felt like summer started
with Shazam for me and like it's just
been the longest summer ever because
it's just out June now when you first
saw Sam that really kicked off a new
life because now you guys are Anna in a
huge universe what's been a favorite fan
interaction sure there's been so many
especially at these Comic Cons but I
think the one that really comes to my
mind would probably be my first
comic-con San Diego comic-con amazing
first first-ever comic-con I got to meet
so many of you guys and I think actually
I think the best moment would probably
be here today I've got my beautiful my
two beautiful fans right here that I
love so much and thank you I love you
guys she actually came from Portugal
from Nebraska and I think it's really
it's just amazing
that I've I don't that I get to do this
and you guys mean so much to me and I
wouldn't be doing this without you guys
and thank you for all the support and I
love you guys so yeah and thank you for
the gifts they're amazing
yeah that's I think also like for me
would probably something here as well I
mean that's some great interactions just
on the streets you know some guys will
come up to me and I don't know who they
are and they'll have a go they'll be
like you're dope Thanks it's a lot
taller than me but I had a really
adorable little girl come up to me with
their parents and I actually had like a
Shazam cast with a little lightning bolt
on it I got the sign I think you
designed it as well she shut us to her
if she's still here you are freaking
adorable that's amazing
now you're talking about some of the
adventures off set and I mean you guys
Jack Dillon grazier like the cast is
full of some some characters was one of
the things they had like they couldn't
have put it in the movie like what was a
crazy onset antic that happened I
remember we had like a giant flower
story that I think came up in Hawaii but
yeah it happens
yeah I say that all the time I'm sure
that I have another one right we have so
many we have a lot of stories um so we
say you guys got sent an NDA first we'll
keep it PG for the while you guys ponder
I'm gonna open up to audience questions
everyone pops in your head now this is a
microphone it looks like a cube but it's
actually a microphone and I've yet to
understand the science but when you talk
into it it goes to the speakers and we
live in the future I'm gonna start right
over here and throwing it is is I trust
you that's what I'm saying okay and then
the to right behind you after you and
then we'll sort it out all right
dive in okay so with the Marvel movies
there's always rumors surrounding them
that some actors don't get to read the
entire script or they get to set and
they're told they're filming one scene
but they're really filming another and
your guys's experience with Shazam is
there any weird stuff like that going on
or do they actually trust you guys to
keep secrets about they don't trust I
trust this they they don't even let us
take our lines we they don't get the
table we yeah we we only get to use a
tablet to look at our
we can't take our lines home and like
actually there was like a super-secret
pass code and they changed it every
three seconds we use an app called ember
shop Oh woah it'll tell them oh we're
gonna change someone over here
it's a new one guys it's updated but
yeah they didn't we couldn't even have
like hardcopy phones no I'm sad tried to
take it home then we got in trouble
yeah shout-out Kim for keeping the Kim
Kim's the script supervisor you love you
that that gave me an idea it was there
anything you just guys stole from set
now that it's over now that it's I mean
if it's a big thing don't tell me but if
they're trying to steal Zak suit with
Jack that didn't really work I tried to
steal the Batarang that didn't work I
didn't end up leaving yeah nothing
these are all very in character answers
I feel like Billy Batson would be the
guy trying to take the battery listen
they caught me every time right I think
I took a rock from the rock of eternity
because I felt like that just made sense
why didn't I think of that exactly it
was on the floor I was like they're
gonna probably get rid of it anyways I
took little pieces of stunt glass from
Dark Knight Rises like you know those
new glasses like rubber so but like you
don't take big things it's just to have
a little piece of like a memory you know
it's pretty cool so I don't take a
Batarang you take a little rock I should
have took something like from the
bedroom
Freddy's bedroom because there's so many
things in there yeah like souvenirs are
red yeah I just really wanted that
Batarang yeah that's all right at the
end of the movie when Superman showed up
was that Henry Cavill or just some stunt
double
it was Henry I'm kidding I don't know it
was it was stuff can't tell you don't
know Jovan I don't know I realized I
wasn't in that scene so it was in your
head can and whoever it was Christopher
Reeve yeah that's the safest answer yeah
I believe Mario had a question but Mario
is now very invested how are you
I buy a chance are you two gonna do a
song together a normal body flow
that's what I've his favorite songs of
mine I mean I don't know I'm down are
you down I'm down we're gonna go to the
studio right after this let's make some
use of that yeah we'll be back
what what uh do you guys like shared
musical tastes is there like the same
style of stuff you like like you were
saying Zach's got some questionable
choices but uh like what's your what's
your music world I listen to a lot of
hip-hop mostly pop music as well I like
I like Khalid he's really dope Travis
Scott Khalifa Wiz Khalifa obviously
similar tastes whenever we're on set
I'll be playing something and he'll be
like the only one listening with me
Drake - we both like drank poppy not
Jake Toronto Raptors Raptors fans in the
audience no that's fine it's fine I'm
not either it's good Justin Bieber
trying to fight Tom Cruise you know
choices get made yeah
Asher actually wants to take on the
challenge actually right he thinks he's
ready
I'm paired to lose see I brought open it
up to fan questions and now it's already
like it wasn't really Henry Cavill we're
challenging Bieber to fights calling to
evolve quickly don't you know better
where the cube land my mom was my yes I
mean growing up I used to watch her
movies and I was like mom I wanted to do
this I really want to do this so I still
watch her movies say this day and she's
been a huge inspiration for me and I did
my first show and we're still I I don't
know it's just her I love her so much
and we were we were always talking about
doing a show together so hopefully that
still happens in the future
that'd be pretty amazing actually wait
and I let us say wait no okay
I watched Asher and Coco show happy
funny I really want to say that sucks
now she's on her okay so if any Andy Mac
fans in the audience yeah all right well
Coco might guess turn and anniemac up so
coming up it's pretty cool that happen
that's pretty cool I gotta say guys I've
met these guys and I've worked - or a
ton and as an unbiased observer
these guys and their families are
incredible like the movies about family
but I've met Asher's family a ton I met
your mom like the heart you feel in
shazam about family these guys have in
real life and it's the coolest thing
like I love that you're like my mom
inspires me and your mom's the coolest
so if you watch that movie and you feel
that heart it's legit their families are
dope and I don't that's so important to
like let your family know how much you
care about them it's it's so important
it's vital and that's kind of like part
of comic culture is letting people know
you'd care about him so I think that's
that's read sorry to interrupt what was
the question again
Oh inspired um I actually wanted to
start acting when I was four years old I
used to watch this show called Suite
Life of Zack and Cody
Disney Channel and I always I always saw
that and I was like I just want to be
like these guys they're in a hotel
they're just having the best of time and
on TV and that's pretty much just
explaining the screaming mom I want to
do that and she was like okay we'll put
you're modeling it okay I'll get it I'll
get it out of you and then uh it I
actually ended up making me want to do
it even more so here we are
what was the both of you kidding this
movie was a giant moment what was the
first phone call like like Peter Safran
says like hey you're in the DCE you I I
just finished my tests and I was headed
to the airport of course I was in the
restroom when my family got the call and
I I come out and everyone's jumping
around hugging and I'm like guys what's
going on you got [ __ ] damn and then I
start running around TSA it's it's
really awful jumping on everybody being
very destructive but it was incredible
moment I will never forget it and it's
I'm just so happy to be a part of this
that - the part of what is it so happy
to be a part of the DCAU
and happy to be here yeah I think I was
at a Costco yeah
it was me and my mom and
I don't remember who else but we went we
had just got out of a Costco I think we
were getting ready for my birthday or
something we were getting some some
last-minute cake birthday present right
actually yeah it was my birthday week so
it was actually like I think a couple
days before and we were at the Costco I
was checking out and my mom answers the
phone and then she just goes and I'm
like what what's wrong
did the card decline like what's what's
the problem and then she she says your
whole team is on the line and I'm like
okay hello everybody and they're just
all in unison so they just say Shazam
and I'm like I love it
cool I'm at Costco I can't freak out but
ah and yeah so I did freak out a little
I like walked away this was like awesome
yes but um yeah I was definitely really
cool Shazam's also unique in that when
you yelled the name of the movie it's
can into the movie like if someone just
yells out spider-man weird but yelling
Shazam totally makes sense yeah what
else have a question the audience we got
the cube right here this front row it's
the James Lipton question she's going
hard I love it I'm the best advice I've
ever been given
question really have to think about that
come on music it I'll take the best
advice I've ever been given is to just
be yourself and also the day you stop
learning is the day to quit because in
this industry and you know and whatever
you guys do maybe whenever you stop
learning it's like you know you reach
the end and that's that's it's the end
game so no puns there alright got man
you got a state let's go on stay true to
who you are and you're always gonna hear
no and if you work hard you could
eventually turn that no into a yes thank
you I agree
thank you yeah that's America the you
have to be more confident like in life
and in music and everything I mean just
be yourself like Johan said just be
yourself and I mean find a good group of
friends that make you happy and support
you and I mean if you have a dream go
for that dream whoa he sounds like a
robot yeah shoot for that dream and
anything is possible
so yeah happy birthday happy birthday
right there we go alright come on you
got a birthday rat I got a birthday rap
birthday birthday so you a happy
birthday Emily yeah happy birthday we
with the Shazam Casas lit yeah see you
once Esther Shazam yeah I like a wish
yeah are you EP coming soon you gonna
see no signal coming soon you gonna see
their happy person happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
yeah let's go happy birthday dear Emily
happy birthday to you happy birthday
Emily I love you thank you for coming
[Applause]
it's you little man
leo that's Leo right your name's Leo no
you look like another kid
you look like Leo what's your name nice
to meet you handy it's a good question I
was me personally I was very happy with
the scripts super excited to audition
for it because they sent me the whole
script and I got to read it with my dad
and I knew that it was something special
and I knew that it and I was really
excited because it wasn't very dark I
didn't think it was very dark and some
movies or DC you know some some of those
DC movies are dark and I was like wow
this is different hi goodbye thank you
for coming I love you guys so I was very
happy with the scripts and super excited
to hopefully get the project I like the
script there's good I loved it actually
I think it's one of the first scripts
that I actually read the whole thing
more than once so yeah that tells you so
much does a good movie I may be a little
biased but I really like how they
balanced the the light and darker tones
the movie itself wasn't dark but like
that movie got scary I really wasn't
expecting that it's amber put some yeah
I mean with the horror background he had
some creepy moments that he was the
script scared like did you imagine when
you were reading there's gonna be no I
mean Mark Strong really brought his
character to life and just the
atmosphere and like the energy that he
brings I remember I stayed back I don't
know if you were there but I see back on
one of the days after I got done to
watch him work and it was when he
reaches in I don't spoil it I know it's
when he reaches into the eye of sin and
he like lifts it up and it's just like
this little boy you don't think anything
crazy of it and he just whips it out and
he's like
and I'm like you just made that same
look so cool and there's no CG guy yeah
I'm like what the heck
so I mean just Big Ups to mark Strong
he's a good nominal actor yeah
all right we got to have for one more
quick one it's up to it's up to this
well-spoken gentleman let's see it Andy
and yeah she's some big hold in their
hand that's some excitement we got he
just raised up for Andy good catch
thanks oh man how did you like Zach he
was okay
he's good a nice guy good-looking yeah
he was great I'm super excited to work
with him Jovan do you think of
zacchara's ACK I love Zach he's he's
just a big goofball wanna say he's like
an adult version of this guy which it's
fitting you know especially for this
movie we're both kids guys so I would
like to send these gentlemen off with
the loudest you know a word I'm gonna
say but I'd like it as loud as you got
you ready
it's count of three three wait really
wait should we get it on film are we oh
I think we I think we got porn yeah we
got let's build it up get the socials
socials okay coy you got it you got it
quite this all right three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
take a coconut so much let's hear for
these guys let's hear for shazam they're
gonna be signing over in the signing
booths go talk to them asking questions
they're awesome guys thank you all so
very much